david tepper owner of the carolina
panthers just last week i'm not a doctor
but i have enough money to buy the
opinion of every doctor in the free
world and then some
he knows and the panthers know and they
have an idea of what's going on with cam
newton and chris i thought it was
significant for a variety of reasons
yesterday that jordan rodrigues of the
athletic.com reported that the panthers
expect cam newton to pass a physical in
march now march isn't relevant to the
panthers because their off-season
program doesn't begin until april it's
relevant for a separate reason putting
it out there that cam newton is ready to
pass a physical in march is basically
putting the for sale sign in the front
yard and putting anyone out there on
notice as they are looking at their
quarterback options yes don't forget
about cam newton he's going to be
healthy enough for you to trade for him
in march yeah uh a hundred percent i
think that's exactly what they're saying
by this uh you know i don't know how you
feel mike you know but ultimately yeah i
you know i guess the longer we go here i
go i don't really think cam newton's
going to be with the carolina panthers i
don't i think it's just a total regime
change there in carolina matt rule joe
brady you know him coming in from lsu
cam newton wanting to learn that new
offense i don't know about that you know
i think they're going to want their
fresh start i'm not so sure cam newton's
going to necessarily want to deal with
them either and he might just want a
fresh start to go along with it so
that's kind of what i see it like you
mike i think it's pass the physical
and then open up the phone talks to
teams and the trade conversation and see
if something can get done that way
cam newton's also going to want more
money and he deserves more money if he's
healthy because he's due to make only 19
million
this year that has him near the bottom
of the veteran market not the guys who
are still operating under the terms of a
rookie contract but for the guys who are
on second contract there aren't many
right now if any who are south of 20
million a year cam newton is and the
panthers look i think chris at a certain
level
they are fatigued by the constant worry
regarding cam newton's health sure it's
the shoulder it's the ankle it's the
shoulder it's the foot it's the shoulder
it's this
and you know
at a certain point you're so worn out by
worrying about something that it's
better to just not have that something
around to worry about yeah so you don't
have to worry about cam newton's health
anymore i think the fans are fatigued by
it in carolina and i think the team is
fatigued by it and this is part of this
new approach and when david tepper was
addressing the media last month when
they introduced matt roll as the new
coach and he was asked about cam newton
and went straight into this concept of
it's important to have everyone buy in
that tells me they've heard enough from
cam newton and david tepper you know he
didn't get this rich by not being a good
student of the human condition should be
able to read people he's probably gotten
the sense from cam newton that maybe he
would like a fresh start and if i was
cam newton i would want one and i think
chargers make the most sense so far and
above any other team trade him to the
chargers let him be that guy in la that
gets people excited about the chargers
if anyone's going to do it it's going to
be cam newton maybe tom brady but i'd
want cam newton over tom brady i think
that's how this needs to play out and i
think yesterday's report is another
step
in that process eventually playing out
exactly in that fashion yeah i i i'm
with you in a lot of ways and you know
just to get back to the health thing i
mean yeah this is a real issue it is
this is the most physical quarterback
we've ever seen in the history of
football right and i can understand
carolina being kind of exhausted by it
too because you invent and create an
offense around this skill set and then
when he's not healthy there's not really
anybody else that can duplicate what he
does
and then you have to kind of change your
offense so it's hard and it is it can be
stressful on an organization that way
i'm with you mike 100
la chargers make the play this is it it
really is it just makes sense in too
many ways you mentioned all you know the
fanfare you want to get a star in la you
know geez the adonis king
cam newton walk into a room in la he'll
open up some eyes he's a superstar he's
made for la that way and i think it fits
you know anthony lin's an ex running
back he wants to run the ball and
control the clock and play defense and
then when he does drop back to throw it
he wants to throw you know 25 and
30-yard lasers down the field all fit
cam newton to what he wants to do so i'm
with you and i'm kind of hoping to see
it really i'm hoping la does make a play
for cam newton
it was the first team i thought of but
you know what sometimes it's the second
team that you think of that ends up
being the destination how about the not
oakland but las vegas raiders as a plan
b for cam newton and your buddy john
gruden i i mean it would be amazing i
don't know if john gruden would want to
venture down that offensive path with
cam newton with maybe having to get the
you know run game with the quarterback i
don't know if that's necessarily in john
gruden's dna but the same thing
it certainly would revive the franchise
that way steal people from certain fan
bases and get them to jump on there and
uh you know i'm not i don't think that's
totally crazy i don't think that's
totally crazy i'm just not sure cam's
the type of style john wants
but for the same reason he would
resonate with the lh exactly he's going
to resonate with la fans who are making
the trip to las vegas and between camden
and derek carr sorry derek sorry block
me again on twitter unblock me and block
me again i'll take cam newton over derek
carr
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports